dass die liebe zuschauer ist ziemlich
peinlich innenministerin phaser die
postet ein foto mit extremisten schülern
sie zeigen populäre zeichen von es
terroristen der muslimbruderschaft und
der rechtsextremen grauen wölfe tja
innenministerin nancy faeser verbreitete
dieses gruppenfoto das in ihrem haus
aufgenommen wurde selbst bei twitter der
hohen eigentlich wollte sie mit der
aktion für das projekt verfassungs
schüler werben es ist wichtig dass junge
menschen sich gesellschaftspolitisch
einbringen schrieb sie unter das foto
doch die gut gemeinte idee sie ging eben
nach hinten los ein junger mann der
zeigt den gestreckten finger wie ines
terroristen populär gemacht haben unter
anderem auch berlins breitscheidplatz
mörder an die summary und zwei schüler
zeigen dass rabia zeichen der
islamistischen muslim bruderschaft und
in der letzten reihe bekennt sich ein
schüler mit dem wolfs cruise auch noch
zu den türkischen faschisten graue wird
auch genannt ihre anhänger sind
antisemitisch homophob und verbreiten
hass gegen arminia kurden und auch
griechen und phaser ja dann ziemlich
zerknirscht gestern die von einigen
schülern gezeigten symbole auf dem bild
sind inakzeptabel ich verurteile dies
scharf da sagte sie darüber müssen wir
sprechen politiker jan schäfer ist bei
uns im studio an man muss sagen da ist
einiges schiefgelaufen sprechen gleicht
aber was ist das überhaupt für ein
projekt das muss man erst mal klären
sein projekt die verfassung schüler das
ins leben gerufen ist vor einigen jahren
das unter anderem vom
bundesinnenministerium also auch von dem
ministerium von nancy faeser unterstützt
wird und dann gab es vor zwei tagen eine
auszeichnung rund 100 verfassung schüler
wurden ausgezeichnet ja weil sie an
diesem projekt teilnehmen das dazu
beitragen soll die demokratie quasi zu
lernen gibt dann einen anderen dem wir
da auch sehen der im hintergrund hat und
aus ländern stammen die eltern aus
ländern stammen in denen es kein
demokratisches system gibt hier wie bei
uns und deswegen war es eine idee mit
einem projekt ja dass demokratie
erlernen so möchte ich es mal nennen zu
fördern so aber das sehen wir nun ist
gründlich schiefgegangen bei einem teil
dieser verfassung schüler dass es mehr
als eine pro woche
wenn es das nur gewesen wäre dann ist
das ein extrem schlechter scherz und das
hätte die bundesinnenministerium
natürlich merken müssen bevor sie so ein
tweet absetzt aber wirklich unsere lage
guckt sie sich die bilder vorher nicht
an bevor sie die hochlädt ich meine das
machen ja selbst wir wenn wir was
hochland ist alles in ordnung ja sehe
ich aus weil erst im großen genau das
ist ja die simpelste regel social media
regeln die die man kennen sollte gibt es
auch keine kontrollen wer guckt da mal
drüber was daraus geht da kann man jetzt
nur mutmaßen in der tat erst gucken und
dann posten ist sicherlich eine eine
gute regel die man anwenden sollte
sollte auch die bundesinnenminister renn
tun jetzt hat sie es nicht gemacht man
muss ja eigentlich fast sagen da muss ja
fast dankbar darüber sein dass sie nicht
richtig hingeschaut hat denn jetzt sehen
wir ja was auch unter dem deckmantel
eines solchen projektes offenbar
passiert bzw dass dieses projekt
offenbar viele viel oder einige muss ich
sagen derjenigen die daran teilnehmen
bis jetzt gar nicht erreicht hat und das
ist ja eigentlich bitter also wir haben
es hier auch mit einer naivität zu tun
gerade auch bei der bundes
innenministerin aber die zieht sich so
durch verschiedene parteien bei der spd
aber auch bei den grünen extrem zu sehen
linkspartei natürlich auch da gibt es
eine naivität ein permanent in gut
glauben dass man mit solchen projekten
zu einer besseren integration beitragen
könnte ich glaube das ist ein falscher
weg und die naivität die muss dringend
abgelegt werden man muss aber auch sagen
leider gottes passt das auch so ein
bisschen ins bild einer doch momentan
sehr glücklosen ministerin in ihrer
bisherigen amtszeit wenn ich mal so
formulieren darf bestimmt die pannen
liste von frau fischer ist nicht ganz so
lang wie die von der
verteidigungsminister in lambrecht aber
sie hat schon ein paar lange aufzuweisen
vollkommen richtig wenn wir in die
letzten monate schauen dann war frau
feser eine person die immer wieder den
eindruck sich nicht richtig erwehren
konnte dass sie es gegen
rechtsextremismus zwar sehr stark
auftritt aber beim linksextremismus
beispielsweise er mindestens ein auge
verschließt möchte ich mal sagen so
jetzt hat sie hier noch ein anderes
problem jetzt hat sie hier rechts und
islamisten auf einem foto oder
rechtsextreme symbole zumindest und
islamistische symbole auf einem foto und
das ist glaube ich mehr als nur eine
entschuldigung die da jetzt fällig es
die sie auf twitter auch schon in die
welt gesehen hat hier gibt es glaube ich
wirklich denn um grundsätzliches wir
müssen überprüfen ob diese ganzen
projekte die es gibt wirklich wirklich
dazu beitragen dass demokratie erlernt
werden kann und wir müssen uns immer
wieder fragen was tun wir mit jenen die
einfach nicht in diese demokratie
integrierbar sein integrierbar sind